he's in the uk right now yeah yeah
offering some free last minute advice
these volunteers are helping eu citizens
to hold on to the right to be in the uk
brexit means something that was
automatic now has to be applied for
for many vulnerable people such as the
elderly and the homeless
it's proved a huge challenge we assist
clients
that struggle immensely with the
application process
with understanding english most
importantly with lack of
evidence that they don't have for their
children or other family members or with
lack of any evidence whatsoever
from thursday eu citizens will be in the
uk illegally if they haven't applied for
either settled status for those in the
country for five years as of last
december or what's called pre-settled
status
more than five million people have
already done so but with a backlog of
four hundred thousand cases
and an unknown number who aren't already
in the system the government's accepted
it will need to be flexible
a week before the deadline the uk home
office said it would be issuing anyone
who hadn't applied
with a 28-day notice it confirmed that
after that period
quote they may be liable for enforcement
action and will not be eligible for work
benefits or services if you're an eu
citizen living in the uk in its official
guidance the home office says it'll be
lenient with anyone who has a good
reason for applying late
and nobody who's waiting for a decision
will lose their rights
but campaigners fear a repeat of the
windrush scandal named after the ship
bringing british citizens from the
caribbean colonies
to work in the uk after world war ii
under a new hostile environment in the
2010s
thousands of people who'd lived in the
country for decades were told to prove
it
in many cases the home office had
destroyed crucial paperwork
some windrush victims were deported
others had their lives in the uk
ruined even though they have been given
the opportunity later on to sort out
their status
people were denied cancer treatment or
if if they were given it
arrived home to find a massive bill or
were not able to
find accommodation we're not able to get
a job
and experts are warning there could be
real problems in the future
for people who for whatever reason slip
through the net
if you have people for example who
simply didn't realize until
they tried to get a job 10 years later
that
that they didn't have status it can be
very challenging to go back
a long time and try and dig up evidence
that you were here
many years ago and that was what created
such a challenge for the windrush
generation
the uk government says it's working to
make sure employers and landlords don't
discriminate
against people who have applied for
settled status but haven't got a
decision
but for tens of thousands of eu citizens
what happens next is far from clear
nadim baba al jazeera london